let's even step back as you mentioned
Tony you mentioned tone a lot what do
you mean by Tone it's all of it together
if you look at
I think you can flip through let's just
take fantasy you know you can sort of
look at a couple images or things and
know how does Lord of the Rings
different from
Game of Thrones that is different than
um you know ethereum like Excalibur or
your you know
Sci-fi channel uh
you know series of the month kind of
thing
um
and so
finding that what's going to make it
kind of unique and usually I lean on
something that is grounded in
reality for what it is
and then have lesser kind of
Fantastical things at least at the start
and then they they kind of build so even
when we do star field I mean it's a
science fiction game there are laser
guns and spaceships that fly around
shoot each other and blah blah blah blah
but it's grounded in you can look at it
and say okay this is kind of an
extension of
things as we view them today in space
and we sort of take the same approach
with Fallout where admittedly things can
get admittedly things can get even a
little bit crazier
the longer you're developing Fallout
content
so just to uh Linger on this so tone
starts at or defining the tone starts at
creating a realistic experience like you
feel like I could walk into this and
this feels like life what's their
technology level like even for a fantasy
world like is Magic how prevalent is it
or are they making weapons and things
and armor
is it for utility is it for decoration
how do they live their lives does this
feel
like a place that you believe that has
some grounding in our reality whether
that's historical or near future or that
it's grounded in some some semblance of
the reality that you and I understand so
that it can feel it's also making it
feel a little bit welcoming like okay I
understand this is that art or science
so like what how do you know when it
feels welcoming and and everything fits
in his ground no I mean it's I guess
it's personal taste some people like
things that are
weirder that have more Fantastical from
the get-go even a game like morrowinds
where we get into some more Fantastical
things it intentionally starts a little
more grounded you know there's a very
classic medieval looking town that you
come into but you look just beyond it or
mushroom trees and giant insects and
things like that so in Skyrim when you
put a dragon in it
what are your thoughts about dragons and
tone
how does that fit into tone
that's a great question
the
it's a ridiculous question but yeah I
just love her I guess I want to bring it
up no no these are the things that we we
debate
um with do we include a dragon
why didn't you include a dragon in
Daggerfall that's what I want to know I
think there's Dragon there's Dragon
Lings they're hard to do dragons are
hard to do so when you start Skyrim say
hey look you know dragons are going to
be a theme you start to start visually
you think yeah they're you know you can
make the argument the dragons existed
okay what would they look like how close
to dinosaurs would they be or what would
they and ours are less I believe they're
less Fantastical looking in general they
look like beasts that could exist in
that World
um and then how we introduce them it's
kind of a little bit of a slow
you know role in Skyrim and that the
people in the world are reacting to the
dragons appearing
and that's somewhat you know mirrors you
want something that mirrors the player
experience as well it says back to you
like hey no these are this is have you
heard this someone's all dragon
well that's what Daggerfall is there is
there mentions of dragons or something
because there are members
I remember being sure
that there's dragons in Daggerfall as
I'm playing it and I'm searching pretty
sure
to my memory look I guess someone would
probably correct me like actually there
is a dragon here
um but I'm pretty sure they're sort of
they're not yeah and then
game I did Red Guard which
um we bring back a dress takes place
beforehand so we have a dragon there in
that game and that was unique to that at
the time